- [Peter] I just really miss him.
- I don't think Tony
would've done what he did,
if he didn't know that
you were gonna be here
after he was gone.
(dramatic music)
- You gonna be the next Iron Man now?
- [Peter] Well no, I don't have time,
I'm too busy doing your job.
(cops groan)
- What?
- I'm kidding, I'm kidding,
look, keep up the good work,
because I am going on vacation.
- [Naz] First of all
congratulations, guys,
Because the movie is amazing.
- Thanks.
- Thank you so much.
- [Naz] And I feel like
I'm finally recovering
from Infinity War, like
after watching this movie.
- [Jacob] Nice.
- And for me, Spider-Man's
dusting was actually
the hardest to watch,
but I'm curious to know,
what were your personal reactions
to seeing Spider-Man get dusted?
- It was sad.
- You probably laughed.
- I was laughing, I was
laughing in the movie theater,
straight up and then like
especially in Endgame,
when everyone was dying,
that was hilarious.
- [Tom] Just cracking up.
- Super funny, like the
part where he's like,
"We won Mr. Stark, we won."
- You're dark, man.
- Good stuff, guys.
- I thought, yeah, I was very emotional,
but I thought, I was emotional
about the whole situation,
but also a little worried about my job.
I was like--
- So we're dead?
- So we're still on for a while, right?
- Because I could've
sworn this was something
we were supposed to do.
- Yeah, but he's coming back, right?
- From your lawyer, like oh no.
- Tom, for you, what was your reaction
when you found out Spider-Man
was gonna get dusted?
- It was actually the same exact reaction.
I was like "That's really
cool, right, but I come back?
"Right, I'm not actually dying?"
It was pretty much the same reaction.
- Like I still have a job?
What I love about this movie too
is that you really feel
like Iron Man's ghost
or spirit truly lives on,
but what were your guys'
reactions when Iron Man died?
- I mean, everybody's
like heartbroken again.
- It was pretty tough,
it was pretty tough,
'cause we've all grown up
with Robert playing Iron Man
and he's such an iconic character.
Everyone's looked up to him
and I think you could argue
that his character's had the
most incredible character arc
from Iron Man One to Endgame
maybe in cinematic history.
We said goodbye to someone who we all love
and we will miss him and
this film is kind of like
a token of our love to what
Robert Downey Jr. created
and Jon Favreau, when he
made those first two films.
So yeah, so it's a really nice kind
of love note to Iron Man.
- You've got to remind yourself
that Robert Downey Jr. is still alive.
- Yeah, he's still good.
- He is still there, you know.
- He's still thriving.
- The real guy is still there.
- I agree, sometimes we forget.
- [Tom] Yeah, that is so true.
- He had such an incredible run, you know?
Like over a decade.
- [Tom] Amazing.
- It's just a legacy.
But going off that theme though,
Tom, I'm curious to know how long
do you want to play Spider-Man?
- I honestly would play Spider-Man
until like I can't walk anymore.
I love this character so much,
and it was like my childhood
dream to play this character.
I'm loving it, I'm really enjoying it.
I'm really loving what
we can do with this movie
and the people that we can kind of touch
and the amazing things we're
able to do with the platform
that this movie gives us.
So yeah, I'm just really enjoying it.
- I do want to ask you Tom
about your bromance with Jack Gyllenhaal,
because I know you've
done so many interviews,
even before you were
Spider-Man about how much
and how badly you wanted
to work with Jake,
so what was that like finally?
- I mean, it was amazing.
It's always a scary thing in the industry
when you meet someone that you look up to
because you want them to
live up to your expectations
and Jake did that and then some.
He's such a great actor
and he's someone I've really admired,
so working with him was kind
of like a bit of a masterclass.
It was just kind of crazy how we became
such good friends so quickly.
I look forward to working
with him again in the future,
whether it's in a Spider-Man movie
or whether it's in a
small little Indie movie
where we, I don't know,
play brothers or something.
But yeah, I'm just really, really glad
that he is everything I
would have hoped he would be
and then some.
- Are the rumors true that it
was hard to get through scenes
because you guys were just
laughing the entire time?
- Yeah, totally true.
Sometimes just laughing at nothing.
There's a scene in the
film where we shake hands
for the first time and
there was nothing funny
about the scene at all,
but we just couldn't
get it in.
- Stop laughing.
That's always a thing though,
like when you're not supposed to laugh,
that's when you can't stop laughing.
- Exactly.
- And then they're like,
"Okay, now we need you
to laugh at the scene."
- You're tired or something.
- You're like,
"I don't want to laugh."
- I don't.
- Not finding this funny.
They're just kind of like...
(dramatic music)
- [Mysterio] What do you want Peter?
- I want to go back on my trip
with the girl who I really like
and tell her how I feel.
MJ, I--
- Am Spider-Man?
- [Peter] No, of course I'm not...
- I mean it's kind of obvious.
- You're right, you may not be ready,
but this is my responsibility.
Saving the world requires sacrifice.
Sometimes people die.
(explosion)
- Oh my God.
- [Naz] First of all,
congratulations on this film.
- Thank you.
- It was so exhilarating and exciting
to see you in a Spider-Man movie.
I was so excited.
There's something somewhat seamless
about you coming into this universe
and playing a character named Mysterio,
given some of your past roles.
I want to know did any of
your smaller Indie roles
inform or influence
your role in this movie?
- Every role you play informs
the experience of a role
and how you play it and all this stuff,
but yeah, there were...
The themes of this movie are,
some of them are somewhat
similar to other movies I've done
so I was familiar kind of with that play,
particularly like the
idea of a rift in time
and coming to another space
and a different time and continuums,
time continuums and things like that.
So I was somewhat familiar
with what that was
and the behavior that happens in that.
I've done a number of
movies about that idea.
Then I think what Peter
goes through in this movie
is similar to some things that
characters I've been through
in movies have gone through.
So I could empathize with
what he was going through.
I've also obviously grown
up and am older than him,
so because of the character Mysterio,
I could impart wisdom that
I had learned in a way
through playing parts
that went through things
like he goes through in this movie.
Does that make sense?
- Totally, and I'm sure it helps
that you've had training
or acting under a bubble
or a fish bowl in the past.
- Yes, absolutely.
I've done a lot of acting in small spaces,
partially suffocated, so yes, yes.
- I want to dive deeper into Mysterio
just because he's so iconic.
He was in issue 13 of Spider-Man.
Throughout the years we've
seen four different versions
of him and he's typically
portrayed as a villain.
So as much as you can tell me,
how different is your Mysterio
from comic book Mysterio?
- I mean, that's what I
loved about what Marvel did
when they came to me with
the idea of this character.
Which was that he's very
different from the comics.
Because, yes, he appears early
on in the Spider-Man comics,
he's an important part and
he's very an important part
in the comics to Peter
Parker and to Spider-Man.
But he's also not as iconic
as some other characters
in the comics.
So it allows you some
leeway and I like that,
'cause we could change
some behavior and we did.
That gave me an opportunity
to add some things
that I think probably
wouldn't have been there,
if you had to stay strict to the scripture
of roles like Spider-Man
or things like that.
- I love just how they connect
your character into the MCU.
I can't wait for people to
find out how that goes down.
It's awesome.
I was just talking to
Tom and he was telling me
that sometimes you guys would
just be shooting a scene
and laughing about nothing,
something that wasn't even funny.
Tell me about this
bromance you have with Tom.
- It's a romance.
I'm really sick of people
calling it a bromance,
it's a romance, it's a legitimate romance.
I find that to be very uncomfortable
when you see two people
of the same sex really falling in love.
He's a wonderful person.
He's devoted to his work, which I love.
He's obsessed with
learning about the craft,
which I love too.
He could be someone in his
position who has a big ego
and kind of walks in with a knowledge,
even at that age though, you
have all your insecurities,
as we all do, and he's just not like that.
He's very honest.
He admits to those things.
He wants to listen.
I really love the way he works.
So when we first started working together,
he's also very gracious and very like...
He's really knows how
to make me feel special
and tells me that he
thinks I'm a great actor
so that obviously goes a long way.
He's just a good dude and we
actually enjoy each other,
which a lot of people
talking in press junkets
about other actors say,
but this is true.
It's true.
- If you were to play Mysterio again,
would you rather play him
with Spider-Man, Wolverine, or Deadpool?
- Well you can cross Deadpool
out right off the bat.
I have so much deep respect for Wolverine
and same for Spider-Man
so I can't really say.
- I always feel like I'm
putting my friends in danger.
(girl screams)
The world needs the next Iron Man.
(dramatic music)
- Are you going to step up or not?
(monster roars)
(dramatic music)
- [Naz] It's so good to
see you, congratulations.
- Thank you.
- On your 11th film in the
MCU and playing Nick Fury.
It's been so awesome
just watching Nick Fury's
kind of evolution.
In this movie, I wanted
to talk to you about
kind of this new journey and new identity
that Nick Fury is on right now.
There's no more S.H.I.E.L.D.,
who is he working for?
What's going on?
- Well he's still working for S.H.I.E.L.D.
and there's still an Avengers Initiative.
It's just trying to
figure out what's happened
in the blip time and what
his new normal has to be.
He knows what his directive
from Tony Stark was about Peter.
He's kind of like that
uncle or grandfather
who's trying to say,
"When you gonna grow up?
"Take responsibility.
"They tell me you're the guy,
"but you're not showing
that you're the guy."
He's saying, "Just let me
be a teenager for a while."
He said, "No, you don't
have time to do that.
"The world is not going
to wait on you to grow up,
"so you gotta grow up quick."
So I'm kind of that pestering relative.
- Yes, and I love Nick Fury
because he also just kind of
keeps the Avengers together.
- [Samuel] Tries to.
- He tries to.
He's the glue that
keeps them all together.
I want to know if Nick
Fury was never snapped,
what would he have done
in the Endgame events?
- Well what he did.
He knew what he had to do
and he had just enough
time to get it done.
He would've been around to
see what Carol was going to do
and probably who have gotten in her way
or tried to tell her another
way to do what she was doing.
- Obviously you've been in 11 films.
Is there a memorable Nick Fury moment
that stands out to you?
- Well, the beginning.
The first one, when I step out
of the dark in Tony's house.
The "You are Iron Man",
"I am Iron Man" moment
which is kind of cool,
made everyone kind of sit up and go,
"Oh my God, this is gonna be awesome."
That's number one.
And watching what happened with Carol
and when Nick realized
there were other people
in the universe that
needed to be dealt with
and the threat was just as viable
from out there as it was from down here,
and being able to learn
that and watch him grow
in terms of being a naive government agent
into the careful and crazy and
kind of paranoid Nick Fury that he is.
- I really loved the Nick
Fury and Captain Marvel
'cause I feel like him and Carol have this
kind of father-daughter relationship.
But you see this softer side of Nick
where he's singing Hey Mr. Postman.
- No, stop.
- [Naz] That's my favorite Nick Fury.
- I'm putting out an
oldies album next month.
- [Naz] I would love to hear it.
- Nick Fury sings the oldies.
- I would love to hear it.
I'm curious though for you how long
do you want to play Nick Fury for?
Because after watching this movie,
I'm excited that he's still a presence.
I want to see him go far into Phase Four.
How long do you see
yourself playing Nick Fury?
- I don't know, I haven't
given any thought.
I guess as long as I can
physically embody him
and make him believable
and viable in a way.
I don't want to overstep my time,
whatever that is.
- [Naz] No, I don't think
that could ever be possible.
- No, Marvel will let me know,
I'm pretty sure.
(exciting music)